♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
HOW DO YOU KNOW IF YOU ARE
LIVING IN A FREE SOCIETY?
HERE'S A QUICK TEST.
ARE YOU ALLOWED TO SAY
OBVIOUSLY TRUE THINGS IN
PUBLIC?
OR ARE YOU FORCED TO LAW AS
GEORGE ORWELL PUT IT IN 1948
FREEDOM IS THE FREEDOM TO
SAY 2 PLUS 2 IS 4 IF THAT IS
GRANTED ALL ELSE FOLLOWS.
WHAT IF YOU ARE REQUIRED TO
REPEAT THINGS YOU KNOW
AREN'T TRUE?
WHAT IF EVERYONE WHO HEARS
YOU KNOWS PERFECTLY YOU ARE
LYING BUT CAN'T SAY OUT
LOUD.
WHAT IF THEY'RE REQUIRED TO
NOD ALONG AND MOCK SINCERITY
AS IF IT'S ALL COMPLETELY
REAL.
THAT'S WHAT A PEP RALLY IN A
POLICE STATE THANKS TO THE
LEADER OF BOUNTIFUL POTATO
HARVEST THEY CHANT EVEN AS
THEY STARVE TO DEATH.
GET THE SAME FEELING AS YOU
WATCH THE CURRENT RACE FOR
THE NOMINATION.
PETE BUTTIGIEG WAS IN THAT
RACE A FEW YEARS AGO WHEN
BEST KNOWN FOR BEING MAYOR
OF SOUTH BEND, INDIANA.
HE MADE THE POINT ALL LIVES
MATTER HE SAID IT BECAUSE
IT'S TRUE ALL LIVES DO
MATTER NO MATTER WHAT THEY
LOOK LIKE.
EVERY LIFE HAS VALUE,
PERIOD.
THAT'S THE MESSAGE OF
CHRISTIAN GRANT AND OF THE
CIVILIZATION THAT IT SPAWNED
IN THE WEST THAT CAN NO
LONGER B ACKNOWLEDGED HE
APOLOGIZED FOR WRONG-THINK.
>> 2015 YOU SAID ALL LIVES
MATTER WHEN YOU SPOKE ABOUT
TWO POLICE CONTROVERSIES
THAT WERE HAPPENING IN SOUTH
BEND.
WAS THAT A MISTAKE?
>> WHAT I DID NOT UNDERSTAND
AT THAT TIME WAS THAT THAT
PHRASE JUST EARLY INTO MID
ESPECIALLY 2015 WAS COMING
TO BE VIEWED AS A SORT OF
COUNTER SLOGAN TO BLACK
LIVES MATTER.
AND SO THE STATEMENT THAT
SEEMED VERY ANTI-DINE AND
SOMETHING THAT NOBODY COULD
BE AGAINST ACTUALLY WOUND UP
BEING USED TO DEVALUE WHAT
THE BLACK LIVES MATTER
MOVEMENT WAS TELLING US.
SINCE LEARNING ABOUT HOW
THAT PHRASE WAS BEING USED
TO PUSH BACK ON THAT
ACTIVISM, I STOPPED USING IT
IN THAT CONTEXT.
>> Tucker: I'M SORRY I SAID
ALL LIVES MATTER.
I WON'T SAY THAT AGAIN.
GOING FORWARD ONLY SOME
LIVES WILL MATTER, WHATEVER
LIVES THE PARTY DEEMS
MEANINGFUL.
I AM PENCE TANT AND I STAND
CORRECTED THE CROWD NODDED
GREYLY WE ARE GLAD TO SEE
YOUR CHANGE OF HEART.
SOME DIGNITY AS HE WENT
THROUGH THE MOTIONS OF
RITUAL APOLOGY.
BETO O'ROURKE WHO IS 46
YEARS OLD AND STILL SKATE
BOARDS.
HE ASKED ABOUT HIS WIFE
STAYING HOME TO SAVE THE
KIDS O'ROURKE FELL APART
COMPLETELY GRABBLED AND
WHIMPERED AND ABASED HIMSELF
AND EXPANDED THE
SELF-CRITICISM AND APOLOGY
DEVISED FOR HOW HE WAS BORN.
>> CONSTRUCTIVE CRITICISM IT
HAS ALREADY MADE ME A BETTER
CANDIDATE NOT ONLY WILL I
NOT SAY THAT IN BUT I WILL
BE MUCH MORE THOUGHTFUL
GOING FORWARD IN THE WAY
THAT I TALK ABOUT OUR
MARRIAGE AND ALSO THE WAY IN
WHICH I ACKNOWLEDGE THE
TRUTH OF THE CRITICISM THAT
I HAVE ENJOYED WHITE
PRIVILEGE, ABSOLUTELY.
UNDENIABLE.
>> Tucker: THIS IS WHAT MAOS
TRIBUNALS LOOKED LIKE BY THE
CULTURAL REVOLUTION.
BY SUMMER CAN YOU PICTURE
BETO WEARING A WHITE DUNCE
CAP COUNTER REVOLUTIONARIES.
PRETTY MUCH EVERYONE RUNNING
AS A DEMOCRAT THIS YEAR FACE
INQUISITION WRITE
CONFESSIONS OF GUILT BOWING
BEFORE ACCUSERS ON SOCIAL
MEDIA AND BEGGING FOR
FORGIVENESS.
KRISTIN GILL BRAND READ HER
CONFESSION ON LIVE
TELEVISION YEARS AGO WHEN
RUNNING FOR A DIFFERENT
OFFICE.
ONCE EXPRESSED SYMPATHY FOR
THE IDEA OF A BORDER.
LOOKING BACK SEE IS KEALY
ASHAMED SHE CAN HARDLY
BELIEVE SHE SAID SOMETHING
IMMORAL.
>> EMBARRASSED ABOUT
PREVIOUS POSITION ON
IMMIGRATION.
TELL ME ABOUT THAT.
>> I DON'T THINK IT WAS
DRIVEN FROM MY HEART.
I WAS CALLUS TO THE
SUFFERING OF FAMILIES WHO
WANTS TO BE WITH THEIR LOVED
ONES.
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO BE
REUNITED WITH HEIR FAMILIES.
I RECOGNIZE AS WE ALL DO
THAT IMMIGRATION AND
DIVERSITY IS OUR STRENGTH AS
A COUNTRY.
I REALLY REGRETTED THAT I
DIDN'T LOOK BEYOND MY
DISTRICT AND TALK ABOUT WHY
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF
THE UNITED STATES STORY.
>> Tucker: TRANSFER
>> Tucker: DIANSFER
>> Tucker: DIVESFER
>> Tucker: DIVERSER
>> Tucker: DIVERSITY IS OUR
STRENGTH.
I ONCE WAS LOST BUT NOW I'M
FIND.
JUST MOUTH THE WORDS.
NOTHING LIBERAL ABOUT ANY OF
THIS, OBVIOUSLY, IT IS
PURELY AUTHORITARIAN, WOKE
FASCISM.
POWER OVER IDEAS IN PLACE OF
THINKING, OBEDIENCE.
IN RETURN FOR DISSENT
PUNISHMENT, LYING AS AN
OFFICIAL POLICY.
AND NOT JUST CONVENTIONAL
LYING, THE ORDINARY TRUTH
SHADING OF EVERY DAY LIFE
BUT TERRIFYING FULL
INVERSION LIES THE EXACT
OPPOSITE OF THE TRUTH THE
KIND OF LIES THAT REGIMES
WHO SEEK TOTAL CONTROL MUST
TELL IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN
THEIR POWER.
THE LATEST OF THESE LIES IS
THAT LOW GRADE MAFIA FIGURE
AL SHARPTON IS IN FACT A
LEGITIMATE CIVIL RIGHTS
LEADER.
ALL OF THE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES CLAIM TO BELIEVE
THAT NOW.
THIS WEEK THEY TROOPED OVER
TO HIS EXTREMELY TAX EXCEPT
ORGANIZATION TO PRETEND HE
IS THE NEW MLK.
>> I KNOW THAT REFERENCED
SHARPTON TAKES THIS PLATFORM
SERIOUSLY.
THIS IS NOT THE PLACE FOR
TALK.
THIS IS THE PLACE FOR
ACTION.
PEOPLE LIKE REVEREND
SHARPTON WHO HAS NEVER
STOPPED FIGHTING FOR SOCIAL
JUSTICE.
>> THANK YOU, REVEREND, FOR
YOUR WISDOM AND WITNESS AND
WORK.
>> A DEEP APPRECIATION TO
YOU FOR EVERYTHING HAVE YOU
DONE NOT JUST ORGANIZING THE
CONFERENCE BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY OVER THE YEARS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
COUNTRY CAN LIVE UP TO THE
WORDS FOUNDING DOCUMENTS.
>> Tucker: THE REVEREND
SHARPTON FIGHTING FOR SOCIAL
JUSTICE.
WHERE WERE THESE PEOPLE IN
THE MID 1990S WHEN AL
SHARPTON WAS DENOUNCING A
JEWISH LANDLORD IN HARLEM AS
A QUOTE WHITE INTERLOPER
JUST BEFORE HIS STORE WAS
FIRE BOMBED AND 8 PEOPLE
WERE KILLED?
BETO WAS STILL A MANNY THEN.
CHRISTIAN GILLIBRAND WAS A
LAWYER WORKING FOR THE
CIGARETTE COMPANIES.
NONE OF THEM WERE WOKE YET.
THEY ARE NOW.
WATCH THEM CLAMOR FOR AN
IDEA THAT NOT 20% OF THE
BASE REPRESENTS RACED-BASED
RAP PAR RATIONS.
>> SHEILA JACKSON LEE FORM A
COMMISSION TO STUDY HOW TO
DO REPARATIONS.
>> WHEN I ELECTED PRESIDENT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> WOULD YOU SIGN THAT BILL?
YES.
>> WOULD YOU SIGN IT?
>> IF THE HOUSE AND SENATE
PASS THAT BILL OF COURSE I
WOULD SIGN IT.
>> I FIRMLY SUPPORT
CONGRESSWOMAN JACKSON LEE'S
BILL TO STUDY REPARATIONS.
>> WOULD YOU SIGN THE BILL
FOR REPARATIONS?
>> YES, I WOULD.
I ALREADY SUPPORT THAT BILL.
>> THERE ARE THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO DO IN THE COUNTRY
THAT HAVE BEEN A LONG TIME
AND COMING.
ONE OF THOSE IS TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH REPARATIONS.
>> Tucker: WELL IT'S LIKE AN
ALTAR CALL.
IN FACT, IT IS AN ALTAR
CALL, THE MODERN VERSION.
BUT THE BIGGER VERSION ISN'T
WILL WE GET REPARATIONS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THE REAL QUESTION IS DO YOU
WANT TO LIVE IN A PLACE
WHERE THE ONES LIKE YOU SAW
ON THE SCREEN HAVE MORE
POLITICAL POWER WHERE HUMOR
AND DISSENT ARE CRIMINAL
ACTS, WHERE LYING IS THE
CURRENCY OF PUBLIC LIFE
NAMES YOU DON'T KNOW DESTROY
YOU FOR THINKING THE WRONG
THING.
YOU HAVE FAMILIAR WITH THAT
WORLD.